yo what up space fam golson here from
anime upper and i'm back at it again
with another hype one piece topic today
we'll be talking about the new
generation of yonko that's already been
revealed to us in the story if we paid
close attention so make sure to stay
tuned for that if you do enjoy these
one-piece videos and want to keep them
coming you know what to do chill parking
within and smash that like button
remember smashing his pirating energy
and passing his scared orochi energy so
choose wisely if you haven't make this
video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates before you
watch the whole video leave a comment
for your predictions about the next
generation of yonko and who will make up
these yonko and lastly while you wait
for the next chapter to drop feel free
to check out my huge and growing
one-piece playlist that includes videos
on all the old yonko warlords mythical
zones and more link to that is in the
description and now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all so
we know the yonko are the four emperors
of the sea and i even had to be told
this back in the day but there can only
be four at one time because in the
japanese four is in the word yonko so
even when luffy was proclaimed the fifth
emperor he wasn't actually being called
ayanko which assumes being in one of the
top four emperor positions so believe it
or not even though many of us have come
to think of luffy as an emperor by now
he hasn't yet officially been proclaimed
a yonko the current yonko are kaido big
mom shanks and the newest one blackbeard
who replaced whitebeard whitebeard was
72 at his death big mom is currently 68
years old kaido is currently 59 shanks
is 39 and blackbeard is 40. so based off
of ages alone big mom and kaido in
particular are associated with the older
generation and are thus the most likely
to be replaced big mom is almost the age
whitebeard was when he died and that's
not even mentioning how much of her
lifespan she probably already sacrificed
through the use of her food powers we
know that she was pushed by awakened law
and awakened kid to the point where she
had to use an entire year of her
lifespan to strengthen herself she even
said at this point and i quote i'm sure
you've come for my throne so take it if
you can prove you're worthy of being an
emperor of the sea end quote and that's
exactly what they do some will argue
that big mom can still be an emperor she
got knocked off the island sure but they
didn't kill her and had to work together
to beat her however oda emphasizes that
the battle should not be read like that
as they're beating her law says and i
quote your era is over end quote oda
furthermore announces kit and law as the
winners it's there in black and white
and their crew celebrates saying they
beat big mom calling it huge news
monumental even so when we consider her
age her sacrifice lifespan her defeat
here her being an old mom and all the
other quotes set in this arc it's clear
that big mom's time is over and she will
no longer be considered a yonko after
news of her defeat by the new generation
comes out perhaps if she had her crew
around her she could have maintained her
public image a while longer but there's
no coming back from this now in my
opinion so who will replace her as we
discuss there can only be 4 yonko so law
and kid can't just replace big mom
together we know that luffy will be a
yonko more on that in a bit so the only
way both can become yonko is if
off-screen blackbeard manages to beat
shanks and in this way mirrors luffy's
success at wano however since shanks is
so young and since he's such a fan
favorite and been hyped up so much it
would be pretty anticlimactic for him to
just lose off screen so what's more
likely is that it has to be either 23
year old kid or 26 year old law who step
in to replace big mom and i think it's
pretty clear that it's going to be kid
in my chapter reviews i've consistently
been pointing out how kid exhibits more
of that pirate king or you might say
luffy energy than law does i mean he
even has conker's haki like luffy does
while law doesn't and goldie roger and
every yonko except blackbeard have
already been confirmed to have conker's
hockey and in my opinion blackbeard
definitely has it too some people argue
that blackbeard will rely on purely
devil fruits to fight luffy's hockey but
i just don't see such a built up
antagonist not also being skilled in
hockey especially since we know haki
trumps devil fruits as you climb higher
in the pirate world aside from law not
having conquerors haki oda always makes
it clear that law is usually reacting to
kid rather than the other way around
throughout the fight the law gets ticked
off when kidd follows up law's attacks
with big fancy attacks that make it look
like kids the actual deciding factor in
the big mom fight law freaks out saying
and i quote i'm not your opening act and
quote and kid responds who cares about
that it's not important right now and in
this case kid is acting much more like
goldie roger or luffy than law is and
despite law desperately trying to take a
man of the situation so that he can get
the credit for beating big mom the
battle eventually ends with a big flashy
attack from kid yes law helps but he's
more like a shadow helping behind the
scenes while kid has that flashy star of
the show's style that will no doubt make
him the star of this battle in the
public's view and as we know public
perception is important for deciding who
will be a yonko and the list of reasons
go on like law's crew is pretty much
helpless during the war while kid has
killer another supernova on his crew
just like luffy has zorro kit has also
always felt like more of a rival to
luffy even having a bigger bounty than
him at one point while la pretty much
feels like a crew member at this point
then there's the fact that kids face
shanks kaido and big mom and come out
stronger than ever during this latest
fight kit has the same goal of becoming
pirate king as luffy while law has
developed other interests like finding
out the meaning of the poneglyphs the
d-clan and their fate and in short the
secrets of the world the good news for
law fans though is that his motivations
make it more likely he'll be there to
assist luffy on his journey while kid as
a rival yonko will not be so willing to
cooperate with him down the line then
there's luffy the new sun god and the
new joy boy he shall come out on top
sooner or later and replace kaido the
second oldest current member of the
yonko i don't think that this will come
as a surprise to anyone since the dude
was already considered the fifth emperor
and he's gotten way stronger since then
and awakened his mythical zone god fruit
to boot his first mate has already
beaten kaido's first mate sanji has
already beaten queen 2 and the list of
victories just goes on so the crew is
definitely already worthy to be called a
yonko crew also unless blackbeard has
been doing some truly crazy things in
the background it's likely that luffy
will have the highest bounty we've ever
seen even higher than goldie rogers
because he'll have beaten the strongest
creature in the world and he'll be the
government's worst case scenario as the
breathing living sun god nika a dude who
literally makes the impossible possible
and who serves as a symbol of freedom
for all the people who are being
oppressed by the world government and
the celestial dragons thus luffy will
easily earn the yonko title after the
events of wano it'll be interesting to
see what happens with kaido after the
defeat if he does survive but i strongly
believe that after luffy beats him
physically and philosophically that the
already unstable kaido will no longer be
a yonko especially since he recently
pretty much said he lost everything
because of the war just like big mom is
symbolically an old mother who needs to
make way for the new generation kaido's
crew is filled with extinct animals like
dinosaurs a fact which to me also serves
to foreshadow his and his crew's
inevitable downfall the old must make
way for the new then of course
blackbeard will stay a yonko i think
most of us can agree that he's been set
up to be one of luffy's final and most
important antagonists if not the
absolute final one i strongly believe
that he will either do something
significant behind the scenes or that he
will show up and do something
significant at wano which will propel
his status and bounty forward as well we
can also imagine that he'll absorb
certain things from kaido and big mom
just like he did from whitebeard whether
it be kaido's fruit like a lot of people
think or whether it be just territory in
my mind the fact that blackbeard's with
moria right now still strongly suggests
that they will show up in wano since
moria is burning to get revenge against
kaido lastly shanks who is even younger
than blackbeard will probably stay yonko
being the only one of the original yonko
of the old era to stay a yonko in the
new era if blackbeard beat him off
screen which like i said would be an
extremely anticlimactic thing to do then
perhaps law could replace him but as i
pointed out earlier despite helping to
beat big mom there's so many reasons
that law is just not on the level of the
other three that to me it further
solidifies the idea that shanks will
stay a yonko at least for the immediate
to near future while luffy's next big
opponent could be blackbeard shanks
could be kid's next target although for
now it is hard to picture kid and his
crew getting strong enough to take
shanks on the idea is probably laughable
to many fans but we know that kid does
have history with shanks and he does
seem like the kind of guy who'd come
back stronger and try to get revenge for
his lost arm it might be a kind of there
can only be one red-haired yonko kind of
situation either way if shanks must be
defeated down the line by whoever i
really hope that it happens on screen
and we fully see what he and his crew
are capable of before the defeat happens
kid definitely has motive to try to beat
him at least even if he doesn't succeed
and he clearly confronted them when he
was way weaker than he is now so there's
no doubt in my mind that he'd try to do
it again considering how much stronger
he is and that is it for the next
generation of yonko do you agree that
luffy kid blackbeard and shanks will be
the new generation or do you have a
different combo in mind or maybe you
think the yanko system will be disbanded
all together let me know what you think
in the comments if you did enjoy this
video and want to keep them coming you
know what to do channel parking within
and smash that like button remember
smashing is parking energy and passing
is scared of rochi energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next video or chapter
to drop feel free to check out my huge
and growing one-piece playlist that
includes videos on all the old yonko
warlords mythical zones and much more
link to that is in the description and
until next time see ya space cowboys